thank you
the threat from violent extremism online
is growing
Homeland Security is warning that online
extremist forums are encouraging copycat
attacks but it's also changing we're
gonna see an acceleration of fusion and
a merger of different kinds of ideology
internet is spawning dangerous new
subcultures in ever more fluid ways
more and more male hatred against women
is rising up through the hidden crevices
of online forums and entering real life
with fatal consequences at least 10
people have been killed this is a
pattern of behavior that should be
intercepted authorities are struggling
to keep up with this new face of violent
extremism
governments are not Nimble enough to
evolve
fear which the online ecosystems are
evolving
can Tech Innovation help to prevent the
next mass shooting
why do you think your assaults and all
these things keep Rising women don't
need men no more
this man Jake Davidson went on a violent
Rampage in 2021 in his home city of
Plymouth in Britain police received
several calls at 6 11 reporting a man
firing a gun close to biddick Drive
Davison murdered his mother before
fatally shooting four others and then
himself
the 22 year old had links to an online
community known as incels
in cells are mostly young men who Define
themselves as involuntarily celibate and
often blame women for their own
inability to form sexual relationships
well you talk about intelligence
smartness
you know women don't give a [ __ ] about
none of that
unless it you got that
in cells often share deeply misogynistic
content promoting violence against women
on platforms and forums
such as Reddit Discord twitch and others
Davison was active on multiple subreddit
forums
it's likely that this is an individual
who was radicalized online
would this have happened without the
internet
that's hard to say but if we think of
two key indicators for involvement in
the incel community which is isolation
and high dosages of online content I
have a huge concern that we will see
increased membership in this community
and increased potential for violence as
a result of that
in 2021 researchers began analyzing
almost 1.2 million posts linked to
in-cell content and sites
over an 18-month period they found a 59
increase in terms and code words
relating to mass murders
since 2014 at least nine perpetrators of
fatal attacks mostly in America are
known to have consumed in-cell-related
content
and in Britain Dr Caitlin reggae now
advises the police on this threat
from a law enforcement point of view we
need to stop the Lone Wolf narrative we
need to acknowledge that this is a
pattern of behavior that should be
monitored and intercepted
in-cell ideology is part of a wider
problem in the digital sphere it's well
established that the internet is the
primary incubator for dangerous and
often bizarre new ideas and groups
but these keep growing and evolving
online in ever more fluid ways Coleman
said he believed his children were going
to grow into monsters and that he had to
kill them after he was enlightened by Q
Anon and Illuminati conspiracy theories
he says he was also having visions and
signs that his wife had serpent DNA and
passed that DNA onto his children
what I'm looking at here is the um
a threat bulletin that we share with law
enforcement Partners local prevention
activists and others
Ross Brennan is the CEO of moonshot a
company which monitors violent extremism
of all kinds online
Al-Qaeda had a really clear world view
and set of ideas
many new Nazi movements have texts that
they've been calling back to for for
Generations these kinds of emerging
social movements ideologies don't have
that
moonshot has tracked how the internet
has lowered the barriers to creating new
violent subcultures and groups
violent extremism in a preemptionate age
needed a certain critical mass and that
bar has been significantly lowered so
you don't need that many individuals to
feel like you're part of a movement
for too long online chatter has been
dismissed somewhat by folks who just see
it as something that takes place on the
internet and doesn't affect the real
world and we've now seen without any
doubt that that just is not the case
[Music]
it's not just the creation online of
Niche communities such as in sales which
is a concern the bigger problem is how
the internet enables these communities
to morph and intertwine with larger
extremist movements in particular
alt-right and far-right groups
looking at the Intel's relationship with
far right we know there is some overlap
in the ideologies both talk about a sort
of mythical Golden Age long gone in the
past where things were different to what
they are today all these kind of
narrative structures appear in both
I think that over the next 10 years what
we're going to see is an acceleration of
the fusion and a merger of different
kinds of ideologies and different kinds
of movements
the British government's
counter-radicalization program prevent
categorizes these kinds of ideologies as
mixed unstable or unclear
between 2016 and 2021 referrals to
prevent categorized in this way
increased significantly
by March 2021 this category accounted
for over half of all annual referrals
a sharp increase from 2016 when the vast
majority of referrals were linked to
radical Islam
the reason we're seeing more of this
ideological overlap or cross-pollination
if you will largely stems from
the shift in ways in which we're using
the internet so if you look at young
people nowadays quite often these ideas
permeate into other communities so for
example a lot of extremist ideas are
being shared on gaming platforms quite
often hear now Gamers referring to other
people as being a chat which is a term
that originated within Intel spaces
this is a really powerful tool and
what's key here really is the threat
posed by harmful conspiracy theories
analysts monitoring new forms of violent
extremism online point to another key
factor the capacity to share false and
conspiratorial information instantly and
endlessly across the whole of the US
after the Buffalo terror attack in which
a white supremacist killed 10 people at
a supermarket in Buffalo New York we saw
over a thousand percent increase in
searches for the great replacement
conspiracy theory a conspiracy theory
that was referenced quite closely by the
attacker in his Manifesto
the proliferation of extremism is also
being encouraged by the normalization of
hateful content on mainstream platforms
Every Day in 2020 humans collectively
spent a million years on social media
where it's not unusual for videos like
this to be widely shared fat ugly sack
of [ __ ] have you ever seen a woman try
and do anything confidently
Andrew Tate is a former reality TV star
Infamous for his misogynistic views
as of September 2022 hashtag Andrew Tate
content on tiktok has been viewed more
than 17 billion times
and he amassed millions of followers
before being suspended in August 2022 by
almost all platforms this content is not
necessarily that Niche anymore but
rather it is being saturated into youth
culture more generally it might be a
funny meme someone puts up on their
Facebook feed that you maybe knew in
high school it's through the higher
dosages that people become indoctrinated
the content really starts to permeate
off-screens and onto streets
foreign
for those in the business of tackling
the threat from violent extremism online
keeping ahead of the enemy is a
challenge one hope for turning the tide
is Designing Technology to intercept
individuals at scale before they succumb
to online radicalization
in 2016 moonshot designed something
called the redirect method with Jigsaw a
part of Google Google searches for some
violent content are met with links to
curated material including links to
psychological help and support we
brought up the advertising space and
tried to entice and encourage those who
are trying to access extremist material
to instead consume material that
undermines those extremist movements
at its core harnessing ad Tech to
counter-terrorism is what the redirect
method is all about
[Music]
there are some encouraging signs
moonshot has found that Americans
consuming extremist or violent content
online are at least 47 more likely than
average to take up offers of mental
health services online
but measures like this are a long way
from reaching the required scale for now
the fight against violent extremism in
the digital world is buffering
[Music]
extremists have always been about three
steps ahead of those trying to stop them
that shift needs to take place where we
take this seriously as a national
security threat because if it doesn't
then this problem is going to be one
we're dealing with for a very very long
time
hello I'm Tom standage Deputy editor at
The Economist if you'd like to learn
more about this topic click on the link
opposite and if you'd like to watch more
of our now and next series click on the
other link thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe